Allegations and confirmed instances of fakery
have surrounded the production of Man vs.
Wild over the years, and there are even some
things Bear Grylls and his producers have
admitted to making up.
So if you ever thought the show was unbelievable,
you were right.
Let's take a look at all the reasons Man vs.
Wild is totally fake.
Although Bear Grylls claims to be a survival
and bushcraft expert, a closer examination
shows he wasn't closely involved in that world
before starting his show.
Which isn't to say he's completely clueless.
Grylls was in the military as a member of
the U.K.'s Special Air Service for three years,
and as part of that unit, he was trained in
combat survival skills.
But Grylls didn't come to prominence for his
military exploits.
Before his big TV break with Man vs. Wild
in 2006, he became famous for his widely-publicized
adventures, including climbing Mount Everest
at age 23, crossing the North Atlantic in
an inflatable boat, and hosting a dinner party
in a hot-air balloon at 25,000 feet.
While these were no doubt grueling experiences,
they don't necessarily qualify somebody to
be a survival expert.
When you compare Grylls' résumé to those
of fellow TV survival hosts Ray Mears and
Les Stroud, it becomes clear that his experience
pales in comparison to theirs.
Mears has taught bushcraft skills since 1983,
to both private citizens and the military.
Similarly, Stroud has served as a wilderness
survival instructor since 1990, and teaches
survival skills to the Canadian military.
So while Grylls may look cool when he heads
into the wild, he's not necessarily the one
you want keeping you alive out there.
The premise of Man vs. Wild is one man alone
against the elements, but on several occasions
those "elements" involved four walls and a
roof, along with room service, according to
survival experts who worked for the show.
While filming an episode in the Sierra Nevada
mountains, Grylls enjoyed the nightly hospitality
of The Pines Resort at Bass Lake, a modern
lodge resort offering two on-site restaurants,
a spa, and other amenities.
During another episode, Grylls was supposedly
stranded on a desert island that turned out
to actually be a Hawaiian archipelago, where
he again spent his nights in a local hotel.
"Sometimes you gotta know…
You alright?
Sometimes you gotta know when to turn back."
On many occasions, Grylls has presented dubious
survival techniques that aren't actually usable
in real life.
While filming one episode in a sweltering
locale, Grylls claimed that you could squeeze
and drink water out of elephant dung.
Survivorman star and bushcraft instructor
Les Stroud, who has filmed several episodes
of his show among elephants, went on record
during a Reddit AMA to debunk that technique.
He wrote,
"It is NOT possible to squeeze drinkable water
out of elephant dung...
Well, it is when your cameraman has soaked
it with bottled water."
In a real survival situation, many of the
techniques that Grylls casually illustrated
on Man vs. Wild could actually endanger people.
And we're not even going to get into the urine
drinking incidents.
The worst is even simpler than that.
The two dangerous moves that Grylls most frequently
demonstrated on his show involved hurrying
to cross through dangerous terrain, and getting
himself wet when he doesn't have to.
For those familiar with the show, you know
Grylls hardly ever walked anywhere, particularly
when he was on a mountain.
Instead, he ran, jumped, leaped, and swung
his way down cliffs, mountainsides, and crevasses.
That may work for a video game hero, but in
a true survival situation, any injury could
drastically decrease your chances of making
it out alive.
A simple broken ankle, miles from civilization,
could be a death sentence.
The smart move is to take your time finding
the safest route.
It may take longer, but it'll help keep you
alive if you're really in the wild on your
own.
Grylls also seems to make a point of getting
wet at every opportunity.
He's rappelled with vines down waterfalls,
gone for swims across frigid arctic waters,
and gone down river rapids on a pile of plastic
tarp and branches he called a "raft."
Beyond the very real danger of drowning in
such situations, or injuring yourself in a
slip or fall, getting wet in the wild is one
of the worst things you can do.
Hypothermia occurs when the body's core temperature
drops three degrees or more from normal, and
it can set in extremely quickly, especially
when you're wet.
On numerous occasions, former crew members
have alleged that entire scenes on Man vs.
Wild were faked for the viewing audience.
In one example, a wild mustang that Grylls
attempted to catch and ride in one episode
was really a tame animal rented from a local
trekking lodge.
In another episode, Grylls leaped over a chasm
of flowing lava, which was actually an illusion
created by hot coals, lighter fluid, and a
smoke machine.
In another episode, Grylls is shown constructing
a bamboo raft.
It was later revealed that a hired expert
and the show's crew actually built the raft
for Grylls before dismantling it so he could
be shown reassembling it on camera.
After controversy emerged in 2008 over the
show's less-than-honest presentation, Grylls
and Discovery both apologized for the fakery
deployed on the show.
Grylls told the BBC,
"If people felt misled on how the first series
was represented, I'm really sorry for that."
The Discovery Channel only went so far as
to admit that small, isolated elements of
the show were fabricated, promising viewers
that future seasons would be more transparent.
To fulfill that promise, a disclaimer was
added at the beginning of each episode to
acknowledge the occasional use of support
crews or fabricated situations.
But as much as they tried to diminish it,
the message is still the same: you just shouldn't
trust what you see on this show.